there was a plan to end sg1 at season
seven and give a cinematic movies
instead
would that have been a better idea
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel yes by the way he's insane
[Music]
so Robert C Cooper was recently chatting
away and talking about the original
plans for the end of sg1 Richard Dean
Anderson was already talking about how
he'd kind of had enough of O'Neill and
he wanted to move on he wanted to spend
more time with his family he wanted to
do more charity work when do you leave
good luck
you too
and ending after seven seasons was
really the mark of a very successful
show all of the Star Trek shows ended at
Seven Seasons it was kind of tradition
they also wanted to follow in the
footsteps of Star Trek the Next
Generation and take themselves into the
cinema
I have to ask would that have been a
better idea than what we then end up
getting now don't get me wrong I
personally loved Seasons eight nine and
ten of sg1 but I know a lot of you
didn't no you can't take away my power a
lot of you considered the aura
Adventures to be a little well silly and
running sg1 and SGA together at the same
time was maybe a little bit too much so
what would have happened if Robert C
Cooper and Brad Wright had got their
original plan and actually got the
Cinematic movie Following season seven
so what was the original plan I should
say that they actually pitched this to
MGM and then the Sci-Fi Network as
originally a movie the episode lost city
was actually going to be the first
cinematic movie the whole battle with
Anubis and the discovery of Atlantis was
going to be that movie and it would have
been epic
the Atlantis was originally actually
going to be on earth the end of the
movie was going to show this amazing
dramatic scene where the Atlantis came
up through the ice which would have been
very very cool the episode Full Circle
where Anubis really showed his full
power for the first time was going to be
how season 7 ended now that would have
been a hell of an ending to the series
and I would say as well that the then
movie that would have followed would
have been I think really really popular
remembering this was at the height of
stargate's power
than that
it's not wasted
[Music]
so why didn't it happen well I spoke to
somebody that works over MGM he says it
did basically come down to two things
money MGM didn't really have the money
to spend on a big theatrical release at
the time but also sci-fi wanted both
series Bonnie hammock was the president
of the Sci-Fi Network at the time and
Robert Cooper and Brad writer both said
that actually they were in a meeting
with her and it was her that actually
said we're going to do both we're going
to have both series at the same time on
the Sci-Fi Network
that's not what they heard before at
that point and it's not what they were
planning so they really were quite
surprised but that was what the plan was
so that's what they went with
now I have to admit
I think they missed an opportunity there
if MGM really had pulled the trigger and
allowed sg1 to go onto the big screen I
do think it would have given them a lot
of credibility that maybe they ended up
lacking I do think Stargate sort of
started to fizzle out a little bit
towards the end of Stargate Atlantis and
maybe the movies and the prestige that
would have come with having big
cinematic releases would have given them
just that little bit more of a push to
keep going but also wouldn't it have
been cool to see Richard Dean Anderson
Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks
Christopher Judge up on the big screen
hey
wow what the hell are you doing here
nice to see you too no no sorry I just
wasn't expecting to see you and I think
we've missed out a little bit as Gators
now I understand why they went with the
television series but
I do feel that they sort of prolonged
sg1 maybe a little bit longer than they
should have as I say I loved the aurai
series I loved those episodes I actually
really loved the way sg1 ended but by
the end of sg1 they were fighting gods
they were battling ascended beings
those last three seasons have actually
made it quite hard for Stargate to
return
there are a lot of big questions about
where the SGC is now that the new movie
new series Etc have got to answer
in some ways if it had ended at season
seven and then we'd have maybe got a
couple of cinematic movies and really
would have allowed Stargate to make that
next step to give it that extra
credibility to give it a slightly bigger
stage
then I actually think the return of
Stargate would have been a lot easier
that's that possible
true
give you everything you wanted your own
lab gets too big
I want assistance yes second
even your own choice of projects well
that's not true other than going back to
Atlantis I mean
and actually if the Stargate franchise
had gone to the cinema and had been
successful
maybe that would have given MGM and the
Sci-Fi Network and other networks that
then jumped in a little bit more
confidence to push Stargate Atlantis on
oh this is where everyone went huh
you okay
I'm alive
[Music]
and I've got you
what else do I need
[Music]
[Applause]
nice view
yes it is
[Music]
maybe then we could have got a couple
more seasons of Stargate Atlantis that
would have maybe then put a little less
pressure on SGU and we could have ended
up getting seven seasons of that
just maybe if they'd have gone that way
Stargate wouldn't have ended at all
maybe it could have kept going maybe we
could have got other series other movies
but sadly it didn't happen and after the
second season of SGU obviously it ended
but
what could we have had
guys get into the comments and tell me
what you think if they'd have gone with
the original plan and given us that
movie and then ended sg1 at season seven
do you think it would have been better
as a whole for the franchise because
sometimes less is more
or do you actually think look it
happened as it happened okay Robert C
Cooper and Brad Wright had that idea but
it's not what we wanted at the time
then okay fair enough but tell me why
why do you think it was better because
I'm not so sure
get into the comments or tell me exactly
what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you know follow all these links that
have been scrolling across the bottom
here they're all in the description as
well particularly the patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where you get to
see most of our new videos first so
please give that a look as always please
stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you